100e numéro pour le journal gratuit
versailles plus depuis 10 ans ce journal
parle de l'information locale des lieux
des gens qui font versailles une ville
riche d'artistes d'habitants de
monuments et d'histoire qui semblait
vivre dans l'ombre de son illustre
château pour son directeur guillaume pas
la honte qui a racheté le titre il ya
quatre ans c'est justement le contraire
versailles est riche d'événements de
lieu pour en faire un magazine c'est
vrai c'est un projet un peu fou mais je
pense pas que ce soit aimé la presse je
pense aussi mais la ville ce projet un
peu fou guillaume le développent avec
une quinzaine de journalistes connus ou
non tous habitants de versailles ou
connaissant très bien la ville
ce réseau leur permet d'être toujours en
avance au courant des nouveaux commerces
des expositions des spectacles mais
aussi des projets municipaux qui
impacteront l'avis dé versailles et son
numéro et des changements de formats
avec plein de souvenirs alors numéro 100
bah c'est vraiment nouvelle maquette on
est très fier d'arriver à 100 numéros 10
ans va un coup de coeur pour le pôle
quartier saint-louis parce qu'on a fait
tout un dossier sur saint louis où on a
mis en avant tout l'artisanat tout le
côté que les gens ignorent parfois et
bien tous ces artisans qui travaillent à
saint louis
un luthier un ébéniste voilà la
journaliste de tv fil 78
véronique ithurbide en plein travail
pour le magazine visite une nouvelle
galerie d'art dans le quartier saint
louis
on vient d'horizons très différents on
ad âge si différents des professions
différentes et c'est ça qui est bien
parce que chacun apporte sa richesse
le journal gratuit et distribué chez les
commerçants mais aussi les parkings de
la ville 18 mille exemplaires qui
s'arrachent chaque mois en quelques
jours c'est beaucoup pour une ville de
75000 habitants
le journal est aussi accessible sur
internet pour tous versailles est ou non